[Music]
we're going to have to make a decision
about human nature to will take if this
is our home to be cherished and nurtured
an incredible pearl flung out in the
universe of ashes and darkness or is
this a hell world a tiny confining
prison at the edge of a dying universe
from which it is our destiny to break
free and recover our higher and hidden
nature from which we have become
separated you know this is a choice
which as a culture we face are we to go
into the divine imagination and create
you know starships the size of Manitoba
that will ply between beer and Andromeda
and exist in a world of our complete and
tactical self-expression or is man's
place calmer than that is that grandiose
peaked with megalomania touched with the
kind of political change that's have
this raping and pillaging ever since we
got out of those miserable icebound
villages and just wonder where ever it
was is
that or is that our challenge and my
destiny it's really a choice about human
nature as individuals and I guess this
is really bringing personally maybe what
makes this song important as individuals
we have been too willing to be talked
and delayed when what is really out
there to blow your mind does not refer
to tation a previously achieved
conclusion but experience the world is
are weirder than the maddest among us
suppose this very small flute team
called both humanists
just will not dummy in Western
civilization now it's always hidden
there it was there before rave before
pub before rock and roll before jazz
before the Impressionists before the
romantics back back back there was
always this strain of
dissent because it's the lifeline of
sanity and every time the bastions of
bullshitter II grow weird the Bohemian
thread expands a function offers itself
as an alternative and I don't think this
is an eternal damp of frustration I
think eventually this archaic
returned which is what this bohemian
thing has always represented will be
felt will be heard we have very little
time now if I believed that salvation
had to come from political institutions
I would just throw up my hands and
despair it's very hard for people
sometimes to figure out whether I lost
them let's get something straight here I
am the most optimistic person you have
ever met
I am absolutely convinced that there is
nothing wrong and that nothing can go
wrong and that nothing will go wrong and
that if something needs to be done you
will find yourself doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]